if i'm an entrepreneur and i'm growing
my business month over month over month
when should i one start taking money out
and two
when should i start actively investing
these are some of the questions i get
most frequently uh with the
entrepreneurs that i speak with who
you know depending on where they're at
they might have uh you know five hundred
thousand a million two million dollars
in the bank and they're like i'm not
really sure what i should do
and so what i wanted to do was walk you
through the thought process that i had
around investing
uh to give you a little bit of some
frameworks to think through that helped
me make the system making process a lot
easier
so first off i'm a big believer in
continuing to take dividends out of a
business
as it continues to grow and that's
because you want to decrease your
downside risk
right because for some reason and the
statistics are very likely that the
business will not succeed in the long
term you know 90 whatever it is 90 or 95
of businesses fell within five years
and so uh it's it's much better in my
opinion to consistently take money out
of the business as you're growing it
because there's a very high likelihood
that it will not
uh stick around a and b many
entrepreneurs have this idea that
they're going to sell their business for
some magical number
sometime in the future when in reality
only one percent of businesses ever sell
and so if that is the case again well i
would rather not stack the chips on a 91
to one bet
it does happen but the likelihood is low
and so i would like to take chips off
the table
table on a regular basis so that is the
first part which is making sure that
we're taking money out
but the second question is okay well now
that i have this money this 500 this
million this whatever
what should i do with it right and so
one of the big things is i just like to
think about this through the lens of
opportunity cost which is
if i'm currently making let's say uh 500
000
a year right from my business in in net
free cash flow that's owner earnings
what i get to take out of the business
after reinvesting in
in the growth and competitive advantage
that we need to continue to maintain to
to grow
right so if i have 500 000 of net free
cash flow that's coming to me
and let's say i've got a million dollars
saved up
if i were to if i were to passively
invest that i should get about 10
ish a year right that's just going to be
investing through uh indexes like the s
p 500 etc
right if i'm doing that then the
advantage of
actively investing might be the marginal
difference but it might be an extra five
or ten percent so
that would be a 50 to 100 increase
because 10 to 15
is a 50 increase right but if i look at
it in terms of real terms
uh just purely on how much my net worth
is going to increase which is the length
that we have to look at this through
which is the opportunity cost
if i were to spend half of my time
thinking about actively investing
because it will take up half your
your mind space i promise you because
i've done this mistake before i made
this mistake before
then what happens is your active income
will fall at a disproportionate rate
compared to
what uh your money is making you so let
me i'll walk you through a numbers
example so let's say
you've got that million dollars and you
can get ten percent a year which is a
hundred grand on
100 passable right but the additional
fifty percent or a hundred thousand
dollars a year
uh fifty two hundred thousand dollars
here which would be five to ten percent
of that million right
you could get through actively investing
well if you're currently making 500 000
a year from your business do you think
it would be reasonable to take half or
25
of your time to go chase that when you
can probably get your
income from 500 to 750 000 in the next
year 500 to a million
and so for me that was always the
opportunity cost of actively investing
which until my wealth became so large
that i felt like it was
the opportunity cost of the money that i
should be making by paying more
attention to my money
was going to outpace my income which is
still almost not there and so for me
that is why as
for entrepreneurs it's my belief that a
you should be ripping out cash on a
regular basis because that's downside
risk protection
it's not your upside it is downside
protection it's the fact that what if my
business does not succeed
as much as i'm a big believer in being
optimistic you also have to face reality
and confront facts which is the
likelihood that
this particular business that you're on
i've had 13 businesses that i've started
up to this point and now i own eight
more
the likelihood that the business that
you start is going to be the one that
you finish with is extremely
extremely extremely low right extremely
low
and the likely that you're going to sell
that business for a big number is
extremely extremely extremely low
and so you take this money out and you
put it into the s p or you put it into
an index because it is passive
and you can put it there and the idea is
that you never have to think about it
again
now the amount of money that you should
keep in cash uh in
in my belief is you should have about
six months two years worth of
normal living that's saved up in cash
and that's just so that you can sleep
well at night and that's it the other
thing is that when you invest that into
indexes why not you can always take a
loan against those assets if you wanted
to start something big so it's not like
it's illiquid uh when it's there you can
take loans against those assets at 60 or
70 percent
uh loan to value meaning if you have a
million dollars in assets
uh in the s p most banks will give you
60 70 percent
of that or at least 50 right depending
on the stocks and
in your history with them etc that will
give you basically for free
right they'll give you that one percent
or two percent uh money that you can go
and reinvest in starting another
business or buy a piece of real estate
or whatever
right and so for entrepreneurs it is my
belief that you should
be investing most of your time and
energy or almost 100 of your time and
energy and growing your income growing
the main vehicle you have
but extracting the money and putting it
into a low brain
vehicle that's not active that's passive
that's truly passive
not real estate flipping that's not
passive right truly passive
if you're in crypto right or you have
some speculative stuff that you that you
want to get into it's probably taking up
way more of your attention
than it should be and it's actually
going to make your main income suffer
which means your net worth will grow
more slowly than it otherwise would so
it's all about the opportunity cost of
your attention all right
now i'm going to put this special note
out here for employees
if the the primary objective of the
employee in my opinion is to increase
how much your income is
and so all of yours and this goes for
entrepreneurs too the the initial parts
of your investment should be growing to
increase your skills
because that increases your basis that
increases your basic income that you can
continue to yield from the marketplace
based on your skill set
and so this is where i think people step
you know they step up over dollars to
pick up pennies
if you were saving you know 500 a month
there's nothing wrong with that but i
would be actively investing that 500 or
1000 or 2000
a month in the beginning into making my
skills more valuable because i know that
if i do that
in two years i might quadruple my income
because that's the thing is that your
ability to earn
is one of the greatest investments
that's not just a billionaire saying it
really is like
you get like if you develop the skill of
selling which might take you two years
you can go from making sixty thousand
dollars a year to two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year or five hundred
thousand dollars a year
which puts you in the top one percent
just by earning that one
skill and so if you can develop that
skill it is worth the investment and
most investments in self-improvement are
so
disproportionately low that it is worth
the investment even if
there are courses that you only get a
handful of things from you are still
as yourself an asset more valuable at
the end of the day you are the source
you're the source of where all the money
comes from so it's like
when people don't invest in themselves
it makes no sense to me
i've spent every dollar i possibly could
gaining access
uh getting mentorship getting coaching
getting programs buying courses buying
books
and and doing that stuff because i'm the
source right if i can improve me as the
machine that generates all the flow of
income
then the rest of the stuff becomes easy
right and so first and foremost you have
to invest in that
after you have an excess of that then
start pulling the dividends out of the
business that you have
and investing those things that are
passive not active and then at the point
where your net worth from your
investable assets what 10 of that net
worth growth would be
is an excess of what you make per year
then at that point it makes sense to
start shifting your perspective towards
managing wealth and growing wealth
rather than growing income
now like i said two employees number one
is increase your skill basis meaning
continue to invest in gaining skills so
that you can be more valuable with the
company
the way you do that is by tying yourself
to revenue streams that means you find
ways to generate the company more money
period and that could be through a
variety of ways if you were you know in
your
your customer success or customer
service or film it then it's gonna be
how can i
send as many customers as possible how
can i retain these customers how can i
track these metrics and show
uh to the people who are deciding my
compensation how i'm directly
making the company more money right and
how losing me would cost my company a
lot more
than what it would cost them to keep
right if i'm on the front end side so
it's going to be sales it's going to be
marketing to be acquisition based
how can i show them what how i can
become more valuable how can i close
twice as many deals
how can i you know close at a higher
percentage how can i get more lead flow
by working my pipeline better
how can i generate leads on my own
independent from the leads that they're
generating for me right all of those
things are things
um that you can do to increase how much
you make
right now like i said if you're an
employee there's going to be a certain
cap
most of the time on what you're earning
and if that is the case and you're
rubbing against that cap
you should keep your your basis for
living as low as humanly possible and
plow as much of that money as possible
into a highly liquid asset again if
you're in the situation
where your wealth right the net worth
that you have is
10 of that amount is still less than you
make then all of your
your attention should still be going
toward your primary net worth increaser
which will be your income
and so if i can consolidate this video
into a single statement
you should it's my opinion spend
the majority of your time on the vehicle
that will increase your net worth the
fastest
and for most people it is going to be
increasing their income
until the point where they have saved
sufficient amount of
assets that they put in passive highly
liquid things like s ps and indexes et
cetera
and at that point when the potential to
earn and increase your net worth
is faster or greater
through the assets that you have at that
point
it makes sense to switch your attention
towards growing those assets
because now the opportunity cost is
shifted away from where your income
is generated versus where your wealth is
growing and so that is my
uh at what point should you start
investing
that is how i break it down first invest
in you increase your skill basis so that
you can
generate more income it is the highest
return genuinely i'm not saying that for
jargon it is the highest return
that you can get the second is that you
continue to put things in the past
truly passive not what people claim is
passive that are really side hustles
but truly passive business so that you
can continue to focus on your main
income generation
and then when 10 of your net worth
growth
exceeds your income capacity currently
at that point it makes sense for you to
shift your perspective
into growing your wealth and rather than
your income so i hope you found this
video valuable click subscribe and i'll
see you in the next vid
bye